on
continue avec shopping parce qu'un
artiste c'est aussi un code barre
[Musique]
or philippe manoeuvre bonsoir bonsoir
thierry alors
y ait ici ce soir pour parler de recul
un concert au stade de france où vont
jouer mille musiciens amateurs l'un
après l'autre ou sousse ensemble par
l'inde après l'hôtel il ya encore plein
de gens qui ont pas compris le concept
est il y à des taxis qui me demande mais
alors il y aura du monde on peut venir
oui vous pouvez venir c'est ouvert ses
publics et effectivement je vais pas
faire jouer 4 mais qu'après quatre mecs
1000 ça serait on serait encore là
quelques jours après c'est 1000he coeur
qui vont jouer ensemble
j'espère aider et le fait que tu es
perdu le banc test va pas je dis comme
je perds le brent et sur whitney houston
ne va pas gêner les rockeurs tu vois
voilà mille musiciens largement le plus
connu c'est vous la main ben oui c'est
bien sûr oui mais moi je sers à fédérer
les nations y aura du punk y aura du
grunge aura du rockabilly aura du hard
rock du métal en voilà au vert mais
c'est arrivé alors est-ce que vous avez
arriver à trouver de la drogue pour tout
le monde
je crois que là jean lassalle du tout
notre problème alors déjà s'il ya une
prise électrique part parce que mon
envie
ça m'a permis de
casting sur internet où chacun a envoyé
une vidéo et vous avez sélectionné 350
guitariste 250 batteur 220 bassiste il
ya soixante quinze chanteurs et chante
et 75 chanteuse karité voilà et puis
tout le monde et où donc on installe les
batteurs dans l'est dans les virages
pour sonoriser tout le stade remet 150
batteur d'un côté 150 de l'autre et
après on fait les mille feux comme un
millefeuille les guitariste et bassiste
et guitariste patti tous les chanteurs
devant et en chine et ont fait le
spectacle devait avoir un batteur quand
il fait un millefeuille après c'est plus
puisque l'aîné on va jouer les grands
morceaux du classique rock pendant deux
heures voilà on a regardé la bande
annonce ok
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
c'est pas mal
en fait l'idée du viano l'informaticien
italien qui a lancé la faire pour faire
venir les foo fighters à cesena mille
musiciens ont joué landes tout fly 48
millions de vues sur youtube on regarde
à quoi s'attendre
[Musique]
ça c'était la première fois donc je n'ai
pas de public c'était juste pour attirer
l'attention des foo fighters qui sont
venus finalement évidemment que sont
venus parce que dave grohl aime bien me
faire un peu le buzz et quand on
l'appelle aussi gentiment il a dit ok on
y va on va jouer pour vous et puis après
il avait pris le goût du truc ils ont
découvert qu'en fait avec des
oreillettes on arrive à synchroniser
mille musiciens ensemble et ça fait un
saut fantastique parce qu'il ya un truc
qui se dégage fait une ampleur sonore
qu'on veut qu'on ne voit que la et du
coup ils l'ont fait dans le stade de
florence une fois deux fois trois fois
et la maintenance eh ben il arrive en
france et après vous le faire en
allemagne voilà c'est ça oui c'est un
truc qui va tenir bon et à un verre que
ça va devenir mondial on espère que ça
va être des rendez-vous ça peut être un
rendez vous régulier parce
qu'aujourd'hui le rock c'est ça il ya
quand même des années qu'aucune major
n'a signé un nouveau groupe pour un
nouvel artiste rock donc c'est
maintenant c'est à nous de créer des
événements rock parce que leurs hôtes
madame encore assez de la main
dessus
et les lobbys sion de rocky 2000 oui ça
serait devenir pérenne de et prouve déjà
c'est de prouver qu'on va remplir le
stade parce que les artistes qui
remplissent un stade au monde y en a 10
il n'y a pas beaucoup plus et c'est un
truc colossal le stade de france dans un
métier pire abidal comme leur comme la
musique c'est vraiment le sommet absolu
et la cedh mille amateurs vont devenir
les super stars d'un soir oui c'est vrai
que
il faut gagner
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça
c'est les musiques de bébés
space oddity petit bébé ouais on va
écouter un autre
[Musique]
en parler
ainsi red door petit black des rolling
stones ou
la police les gones se seraient rockabye
baby giro que baï baby dont j'ai mis ça
parce que je vais me parler du lycée de
lille i rocks vos enfants ils vont bien
ils sont fabuleux ah ouais avais je
gagne parfois je me dis mais qu'est ce
que je fais pour que je fais tous ces
trucs là quand je les vois arriver
dix au démon franchement c'est les
autres et petits rockeurs il mais ils
sont ils sont adorables vous savez quand
s'est marié le même jour ah oui le 21
juin 2014 avec la même femme
bordel dans ce que tu ne sais pas c'est
qu'il ya pratiquement la même différence
d'âge entre candice et vous et audrey et
moi oui c'est vrai ça nous ça nous des
générations et ça nous revient seule une
seule mais c'est un grand bonheur d'être
avec une voilà une femme qui me soutient
dans ce projet des manques en même temps
que rate pas sa scolarité à cause de ça
alors
finalement
in your life est-ce que vous avez été
plus sex drugs rock'n'roll rock'n'roll
alors je serais mort ouais non parce que
moi c'est la musique j'étais venu pour
la musique alors évidemment il ya des
gens qui en en venant pour la musique
ont découvert la drogue ou des trucs ils
sont partis là dedans mais moi pas moi
j'étais là pour le rock et donc j'ai
toujours défendu sa essayé de me
bagarrer pour le rose pour aider les
musiques les plus anciens déjà ses
musiciens anglo saxons les aider nous
aider à les comprendre qu'est ce qu'ils
voulaient qu est ce qu il disait que ce
qu'ils racontaient c'était des gangs
mirifiques ans il était fasciné par
cette bad boy des rolling stones moi
j'ai il habille sa biais d'une certaine
façon tous les lycéens de france
s'habiller pareil on apprenait qu'il
fumait de l'herbe tout le monde voulait
fumer de l'herbe au fusil on était prêts
quoi tout le temps quand on parle des
beatles tout le temps quand il se marier
je me marier quand ils y pensaient se
divorcer et quand il se droguait je me
droguais voilà c'était nos maîtres et
ils ont fait on a tout fait c'est quoi
exactement est aujourd'hui sont encore
là les stones et nous on est encore là
et c'est merveilleux quoi donc voir et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu